hey I just seen and yes I'm sitting on a
donkey and yes I've got a gun and all of
this fun stuff
welcome to the premiere week of the
plunge in five going to be a new show
every week two episodes a week check it
out
hi guys i am at the historic sushi
awesome
we are here in beautiful Echo Park so
I'm here in Chinatown I'm here at
Griffith Park and with your next video
gonna be the Foo Fighters
this week we can have videos for it's
all celebrity cameos here with our
animated videos for you today got a
video for you Rihanna's disturbia and
then I'm going to show you a bunch of
little
and guess what we're gonna have open
casting calls for all of you guys to do
what I'm doing to take your job you're
gonna take
thanks for hanging out with me here on
this plug did five I'll check you guys
next episode
you